[Musica]
buongiorno a tutti salve io mi chiamo
simone trimarchi e oggi ho 40 anni ne
faccio 41 a maggio in verità in questa
foto invece di anni ne avevo ventitré
mettiamo subito le mani avanti signori
tutti abbiamo avuto un momento della
nostra vita in cui sbagliavamo
parrucchiere quello era il mio senza
dubbio il 2001 e questa foto racconta un
po la mia storia è anche il perché sono
qui mi presento brevemente io sono un
ingegnere elettronico che ha lavorato
sempre in ambito digitale che come primo
lavoro ha fatto l'autore test in rai è
una cosa molto strana per il mio corso
di studi in verità è come è successo
appunto il motivo è in questa foto ed è
lo stesso motivo che mi ha portato qui
su questo palco e che è un momento per
me che mi riempie di orgoglio e di
emozione nel 2001 io sono diventato il
primo campione italiano di starcraft un
videogioco online
ho preso il mio primo volo
intercontinentale della mia vita
per aggiungere seoul in corea del sud e
partecipare alle prime olimpiadi dei
videogiochi
allora oggi più che all'epoca in cui ho
cominciato io i videogiochi sono una
parte importante della società moderna
chiunque di voi ha un figlio in sala sa
benissimo di che cosa parla
magari si chiede cosa ci trova il
proprio ragazzo a passare ore davanti a
uno schermo e come è fatto il mondo con
cui interagisce con i suoi amici online
allora questi sono alcuni degli amici
che io ho conosciuto online durante la
mia carriera di della verità sono
migliorato col tempo si vede penso che
si veda e ecco un tempo erano player
campioni oggi sono imprenditori web star
e
quello in mezzo con i belgi attaccati
alla camicia il mio datore di lavoro
attuale tra l'altro quindi io con i
videogiochi online
ho fatto anche networking risparmiandomi
un sacco di scene noiosissime secondo me
e qualche festa bizzarra detto questo
volevo farvi una domanda qual è stato
per voi il momento in cui avete deciso
di comprare una connessione ad internet
se tutti si ricordano la leva che gli ha
convinti ad entrare in questo mondo che
si stava insomma sviluppando intorno a
noi che adesso è così importante per me
è appunto è stato un videogioco quake
nel 1997 col 28 è rotto ha cominciato a
navigare
prima di praticamente tutti i miei
coetanei e tra l'altro quake alla stessa
età più o meno di mirka e uno dei primi
applicativi veramente per connettere le
persone online
vi ricordate di mirko è un client di
chat dove le persone si ritrovano in
stanze tematiche tanto esiste ancora
quindi se volete potete usarlo a parlare
di diversi argomenti ecco mirc è stata
una leva che io vedevo nei miei appunto
colleghi per esempio all'università per
acquistare una connessione a internet su
questo è un aneddoto c'era mio collega
di corso che su milk provava a
rimorchiare a trovare la ragazza
dall'altro nessuno di noi pensava che ce
l'avrebbe mai fatta anzi pensavo che al
limite avrebbe incontrato nuovo in
verità quando andrò a un blind eight su
organizzato su mirka nella vita reale si
presentò davvero una ragazza e la
reazione dei miei colleghi di corso fu
tipo istantanea telefono pronto telecom
sì volevo installare una linea internet
quindi
quella è stata appunto la leva che io ho
visto nelle persone è una leva
potentissima ovviamente per installare
una connessione a casa io però già avevo
una linea isdn da tempo perché dovevo
giocare online
allora questi siamo io akira e sme fron
sono due nickname due nomi di battaglia
di solito si scelgono la prima volta il
tu giochi online a qualcosa e poi te li
tieni per tutta la vita il suo tra
l'altro è un po ridicolo perché l'ha
creato digitando a caso sulla tastiera
che aveva provato simone 78 goku questi
che una prova in l'inizio quando si
scrive una piattaforma online però sono
sempre occupati non so se avete presente
la sensazione di fastidio e devi
inventarti non altro lui fece così è
uscirne forse dovuto tenere qui siamo
nel 2004 a milano a giocare un torneo
insieme come compagni di squadra
loro due invece un nickname non ce
l'hanno ancora sono il mio primo figlio
francesco e il suo primo figlio mattia
io e simone siamo amici da vent'anni
all'inizio quando l'ho conosciuto era un
mucchio di pixel su uno schermo
poi abbiamo fatto un figlio più o meno
nello stesso periodo e siamo diventati
motore di essere amici ci siamo
frequentati molto ci frequentiamo
volterà cena a casa mia
sabato scorso la connessione l'ha
permessa un gioco pensate
tra l'altro non sarebbe mai stato
possibile altrimenti perché lui di roma
nord e io sono di roma sud e cita non ci
si incontra e se soprattutto se l'avessi
incontrata e diffidato di lui in quanto
roma nordino non sono razzista ma quelli
di roma nord se la cercano ovviamente
scherzo scherzo
soprattutto perché
nei videogiochi online la cosa
interessante è che non esistono
discriminazioni non possono esistere
perché dietro lo schermo non c'è paura
non c'è ricco non c'è donna non c'è uomo
non c'è nero e bianco siamo tutti uguali
tutti uguali da una piattaforma studiata
per competere studiata per far vincere
il più forte il più determinato il più
creativo
oppure chi ha una connessione più veloce
nel mio mondo effettivamente il valore
di una connessione è anche quello
nominale c'è più veloce e più hai più
possibilità di vincere però io credo che
le connessioni che realmente vincono poi
nei videogiochi online siano le
connessioni che rimangono più in
profondità come quelli appunto che
riguardano la mia vita che rappresentato
adesso adesso vi faccio vedere qualcuno
che non riguarda la mia vita
[Musica]
[Applauso]
avete capito cosa stava c'è una scritta
sul terreno di gioco
minecraft è fatta con la lav ha sentito
mary mi vuoi sposarmi minecraft è un
mondo digitale persistente due giocatori
raccolgono delle risorse poi possono
creare delle vere e proprie opere d'arte
oppure sfidarsi fare varie cose chi
giocava in questo momento è la ragazza
del nostro artista che ha ricevuto così
una splendida e sicuramente inaspettata
proposta di matrimonio ma una proposta
di matrimonio vera non un game
ve lo dico perché ci sono video giochi
online in cui effettivamente gli avatar
si possono sposare per ottenere dei
bonus ma questo parlando di un'altra
cosa qui vissero felici e contenti nella
vita vera
i videogiochi quando ci connettono le
altre persone possono spingerci andare
anche il meglio di noi stessi questa è
una cosa bellissima secondo me non sono
solo sparare ad ogni pixel che si muove
nonostante che quello sia molto
divertente e quindi non lo sminuiamo ma
voglio raccontarvi un'altra storia il 10
marzo poco tempo fa lo streamer shroud
mentre nile live strisce ha raggiunto i
regoli 100.000 abbonati
vi vedo spaesati cos'è uno streamer
cos'è tweak che shroud andiamo con
ordine
trichet è una piattaforma di live
streaming è stata acquistata da amazon
per circa un miliardo di dollari dal suo
fondatore justin kan nel 2014
uno screamer e di solito un gamer che
mostra la sua partita online ad altre
persone che sono con e se quel momento
per guardarlo shroud ciao dello
streetwear più famoso di oggi ha da poco
superato ninja i vostri figli sicuamente
lo conoscono è quello più capelli verdi
magari avete visto anche voi perchè han
dato su tutti i giornali sono tutti
americani tornando a crowd e al 10 marzo
quando si è accorto di superare il
record
tra l'altro lui guadagna 3 dollari e
mezzo da ogni abbonato su 100.000 i
conti fateli voi io vado avanti con la
mia storia
come superare le corde ha visto che in
chat c'era un'altra streamer che lui
conosce jennifer sci perché si conoscono
perché lui era un professionista di
counter strike e l'ha conosciuta degli
eventi questa ragazza a questa ragazza è
stata diagnosticato un cancro al colon e
sta con la sua stream cercando di fare
una raccolta fondi per pagarsi le forlì
che cure
cosa fa cloud dice a tutti i suoi utenti
che in quel momento la stanno seguire di
andare nel canale jennifer e di donare
qualcosa per aiutare lui stesso non era
2.500 dollari
questa la reazione di jennifer
chiaramente è riuscita ad ottenere il
gol dei 5.000 dollari che le servivano
per le cure è un'innovazione che
internet deve al mondo dei videogiochi è
nata come punto di incontro tra le
community di gamer che si ritrovano
sotto l'egida di questi streamer che
sono de facto dei community manager
mischiati a dei creatori di contenuti ve
l'avevo detto che lavoro nel digital e
anche io sono su pc ci sono con le mie
telecronache appunto io sono un cast era
come mi hanno presentato e durante
alcuni eventi dal vivo alcune menti
online presto la mia voce alle sfide dei
ragazzi che appunto competono online
però anche portando un estratto dura
poco il occhio però perché c'è ritorno
di fiction che dopo la rotation riesce a
prendere che segnerà di campanella
riuscito a fare lavorare calumet
ricaduta
invece contro su giorno e poi ancora
omega con toro 21 contro la mente sono
cercati tradurre le emozioni che loro
stanno vivendo anche per gli spettatori
però recentemente sono andato sul pc
anche per provare proprio essere io l'ho
intrattenitore è a giocare giocare al
gioco in cui sto competendo adesso che è
magic parleremo dopo
anche di magic è una sensazione strana è
diverso dal giocare da solo ovviamente
intanto ti devi pettinare bene e non
devi dire parolacce per un quarantenne
abbandonare proprio abitudini non è
facile
oltre a questo si instaura un rapporto
bellissimo ragazzi che mi seguono
io ci sono poi sono venti persone però
ci prova uno scambio di opinioni
continuo io parlo con loro loro parlano
come io imparo da loro e spero che loro
imparino da me no devi dargli la
respirazione interessante lo
guarderebbero comunque il fan di
videogiochi guarderebbe questo tipo di
live ma non guarderebbe però bella massi
grande grande piacere l'idea
ecco non solo però tutti più giovani di
me
dietro questo è il claim si cela il mio
migliore amico massimo lui
emigrato da poco ed è andato a lavorare
per il real madrid dello sviluppo di
videogiochi mobile una società che si
chiama king e tra l'altro stata fondata
da un italiano
peccato che non abbia sede nell'assolata
spagna bensì in svezia e ovviamente mi
manca mi mancano le partite che facevamo
insieme a mezzi quando io andavo a casa
solo a giocare però con twitch riusciamo
di nuovo a connetterci è come se fosse
vicino a me è appunto dicevano una
sensazione bella allora continuando
abbiamo parlato di connessioni tra
coppie connessioni tra amici connessioni
tra compagni di squadra non abbiamo
parlato però delle connessioni secondo
me più importanti che il gioco però non
il videogioco in generale ci permette
cioè il gioco è un dialogo un dialogo su
una piattaforma neutra dove tutti
possono parlare come abbiamo detto prima
senza differenza tra l'altro noi gamer
abbiamo linguaggio strano gl hf vuol
dire good luck under farne della prima
cosa e dove dovrebbe dire prima di una
partita online perché sennò non rispetta
la netiquette
poi parliamo diciamo tra yard aree o
altre parole è strani sembrano degli
alieni quando parliamo però invece siamo
solo esterofili questa è la verità
ed ecco la connessione con i giovani è
quello che questi videogiochi mi stanno
permettendo anche quando vado a
presentare gli eventi
io li vado a stanare questi giovani
d'oggi di cui i miei coetanei parlano
così male tipo perché sono dei
[ __ ] sempre davanti a uno
schermo e io ho scoperto che questa non
è la verità che ne esistono di
intelligenti ne esistono di educativi
politicamente impegnati di sognatori
esattamente come lo ero io perché volevo
vedere se effettivamente le cose sono
cambiate da 20 anni fa e io credo che
abbiano solo bisogno di essere ascoltati
da una cosa che questa società adesso mi
sembra mancare allora qui sono a un
torneo di magic che l'avevo detto che
saremmo tornati sulle carte fisiche io
non sono riuscito a smettere di
competere purtroppo in vita mia
non ci riesco non riesco a farne a meno
le mie mani non sono abbastanza veloci
per starcraft forse manco il cervello ma
per magic ancora reggono qui sono ad un
torneo e stavo giocando con mattia al
nome di fantasia commesso ancora bella
emoticon per come nel viso perché lui ha
11 anni quando nell'ora circa che
abbiamo passato a giocare insieme
abbiamo parlato un po di tutto
lui ha detto che non guarda youtube che
ha fatto una cosa che mi ha stupito che
legge gli piace leggere e che va molto
bene a scuola e la sua scuola non ci
sono bulli
quindi abbiamo avuto un dialogo
perfettamente normale tra due persone
che avevano vent'anno 29 anni
indifferenza ed è ecco ha permesso
ripeto un gioco tra l'altro per andare a
questo torneo io non sono andato a una
cena tra genitori che mia moglie aveva
organizzato con i genitori degli amici
dei miei figli ha sempre difficile
questa frase è complicata e ogni tanto
mi costringe tutti sanno il lavoro che
io faccio e quindi ci sono molte persone
che vengono da me mi chiedono
spiegazioni sui videogiochi e cioè la
cera questa mamma e mi è rimasta
impressa la lei era terrorizzata dai
videogiochi totalmente e quindi aveva
deciso di limitarle assolutamente
l'accesso ai suoi due figli a un'ora a
settimana un ipad per due bambini un'ora
a settimana
tra l'altro la scienza dice l'altro ma
lei era molto impaurita perché non
conosce l'argomento e mi ha chiesto ma
quando poi si arrabbiano quando io le
voleva del normale e io le volevo dire e
te credo che è normale un'ora a
settimana due bambini uno ipad
i miei figli francesco e luca 74 anni
invece non hanno limiti nell'uso dei
videogiochi
perché io non credo che videogiochi
siano nostri nemici io credo che i
videogiochi anzi possano essere dei
nostri potenti alleati però bisogna
saperli usare
nella saper scegliere il gioco giusto e
quando dico a loro che è ora di cena lo
non dicono a e vengono subito a cena con
me e non fanno nessun capriccio sapete
quando fanno i capricci
quando mi chiedono un papà giochiamo
insieme papa fai una partita con noi
giochiamo in tre
eccoli magari si impuntano proprio è una
cosa che chiaramente io racconto con
grande emozione quando gioco con loro
siamo completamente connessi ed ecco una
cosa uno spazio che io consiglio di
riprendere a tutti credevi shiller che
non è proprio l'ultimo arrivato uno dei
più grandi pensatori tedeschi della
storia ha scritto che l'uomo gioca solo
quando è un uomo nel pieno senso della
parola ed è completamente uomo solo
quando gioca è una bellissima frase
secondo me molto adatta ai tempi che
corrono tempi in cui le connessioni
quelle più importanti sembrano un po
sfuggirci di mano
e allora io vi do un consiglio
riappropriate vene riappropriamo ce n'è
tanto è facile basta una partita glh e
fa tutti
[Applauso]